foreign
[Music]
for Monday May 8th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
for at least a year some employees at
Tick Tock were able to find what they
described internally as a list of users
who watched gay content on the popular
app that's according to former employees
staff raised concerns about this
practice to higher level Executives a
tick tock spokesperson said the company
changed its policy on how it compiles
this data where it's stored and who has
access to it nearly a year ago Tick Tock
is already facing questions about its
data privacy with lawmakers in the U.S
concerned about whether the Chinese
government could access it through the
company's beijing-based parent bite
dance with me to discuss this situation
is our social media reporter Georgia
Wells so Georgia tell us exactly what
did former employees say was on this
list and how was it made so Tech talk
organizes all of the videos that are
uploaded to its platform into this web
of clusters and the Clusters are based
on topics and many of them are kind of
like expected like animal videos one of
the topics was LGBT
and the reason that's interesting is
because these topics also had these sets
of Affiliated users who were watching
that type of content and for the LGBT
cluster former Tick Tock employees
essentially viewed it as a list of the
apps gay users what is Tick Tock said
about the existence of that cluster Tick
Tock has said that the dashboard that
employees use to access this data has
been deleted and that has removed the
names of these clusters and just
replaced them with numbers this data now
lives in this separate unit that Tick
Tock has created to kind of Safeguard
its user data the spokeswoman said that
Tick Tock does not identify potentially
sensitive information such as sexual
orientation or race of users based on
what they watch she also said Tick Tock
does not infer such information right
and we should add that Tick Tock says
only authorized employees can access the
data in this new unit Georgia what did
former employees tell you about how
accessible the data used to be before
tiktok moved it before Tech talk moved
it did have protocols for who could
access it however former employees said
that those protocols were way looser
than what they've seen at other
companies how common is it for social
media companies like Tick Tock to
compile lists like this other companies
certainly can do this social media and
AD tech industry practices though you
know in recent years have started to
discourage tracking potentially
sensitive traits such as sexuality and
the reason is that this data can
essentially create a list of vulnerable
users and parts of the world where like
some LGBT people face harassment and
violence why exactly did the former
employees find the existence of this
cluster concerning so Tick Tock
employees in the US the UK and Australia
raise concerns about this practice to
their bosses and they were saying
essentially what they worried about was
that employees might share this data
with the outside parties or that this
could be used to Blackmail users another
reason why social media companies and AD
Tech players are kind of lobbied to
reduce tracking this type of information
is because particularly in the
advertising world this data could
inadvertently out someone you know
especially if they're like using a
shared computer and like other people
come across it was this the view of all
employees or were there some who didn't
think it was such a bad thing to have a
cluster like this so internally some of
the employees actually argued that this
data was safe to collect and their
argument was that it didn't indicate
whether users really were members of a
particular group so like for example
just because someone watched a video
about gay culture doesn't mean that
they're gay but other employees
disagreed and their argument was that
the topics of videos a user watched was
often enough to infer aspects of their
identity particularly for topics like
sexuality and where did Tick Tock kind
of come down in that argument eventually
so a spokeswoman for Tech talk said that
the data represents users interests and
is not necessarily a sign of someone's
identity so like users who engage with
LGBT content on Tick Tock might not
identify as LGBT just as there are
people who enjoy baking content but are
not Bakers themselves we've seen Tick
Tock kind of in the hot seat with
lawmakers lately on the state and
federal level and there's this concern
that Tick Tock through its parent
company bite dance might be forced to
share information with China how does
your reporting fit into that bigger
picture so Tick Tock has tried to be
more transparent about how it handles
data gathering on its users and it's
built this new subsidiary to house U.S
data that it says should eliminate the
concern that Tick-Tock user data could
be subject to Chinese law the Biden
Administration has demanded that tick
tock's Chinese owners sell their stakes
in their app or face a possible us ban
Tick Tock has also said that a forced
sale will not address perceived security
risks does this reiterate some of their
concerns that possibly Tick-Tock is
gathering information on its users that
might be detrimental to U.S citizens who
are using the app I mean just in general
U.S lawmakers who are critical of tick
tock have had two major concerns one is
the app's algorithm which this reporting
does not get into but the other concern
has been us user data and the concern
that Tick Tock could be forced to hand
over information on U.S users to the
Chinese government and I think for a
long time there were a lot of questions
about how sensitive is that user data I
think this was one of the most kind of
specific examples of how this data could
be sensitive for some users tick tock's
response at this point in time is that
this data is now locked down in
usds which is the name of tech Talk's
new U.S unit
and only employees in that unit have
access to this data but much of this
data is from 2020 and 2021 and at that
time many employees in China had access
to this data and what is Tick Tock said
about those claims that it might be
forced to share data with the Chinese
government a spokeswoman for tick tock
said Tick Tock has not been asked nor
has it provided any U.S user data to the
Chinese government can the U.S do
anything to prevent Tick-Tock from
collecting this kind of information or
from you know clustering it all together
to make these inferences about users
there is no comprehensive U.S Privacy
Law that regulates the practice of
collecting sensitive information seven
states have passed privacy laws
including some that require companies to
protect certain categories of sensitive
data including gender and sexual
identity but there's no catch-all here
that protects all users across the U.S
alright that's our reporter Georgia
Wells thanks for joining us Georgia
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
foreign